投資朋友
歡迎收聽早晨財經速解讀
現在是臺北時間
2026年10月2號禮拜五早上8:31
大家早安
我是游庭皓
每天ㄢ開盤前半小時
我們在這邊陪伴著各位
一起解讀國際財經新聞
即時變化
美債殖利率終於開始回落不過呢
美國股市的拉抬效果還是很有限
原因在於美國股市
本來就在高位做震盪
而且這一次美債市場的反彈
其實部分是來自於目前法國
的財政問題引發的避險需求
是因為法債拋售的情況相對比較惡劣
所以導致美債有一點喘息空間
這一次美國2年
期公債殖利率稍微下滑10個基點
來到4.78%
10年期的殖利率也下降了5個基點
來到5.24%
聯準會的副主席傑佛森表示
現在正在評估是否即要進一步升息
可能會有更多的時間
那的確緩解了10月份升息的擔憂
不過呢
全球10年
期公債殖利率在整個第三季
基本上都在快速地沖高
那現在呢
又有國債市場的重重壓力
混合起來
其實它也不是美國單純的問題
全球都在面對利率會
維持更高更久的壓力
美國法國日本
不同的債市問題會互相傳染
如果法國更加嚴重
其他國家的公債會稍微好過一點
那另外一個國家更嚴重
那也可能又會導致
下一個國家稍微緩和一點
但是大家殖利率其實都在走高
所以從這樣的一個角度來做思考
那就變成了
對於償債而言
市場的不信任角度就來得越來越大
我們過去提過
如果是從債券的恐慌指數
MUV指數來做觀察
拿來跟股票市場的恐慌指數VIX
它完全屬於不同位階
所以的確
及長債市場的賣壓
大家也沒有恐慌到必須要
全面出清股票市場的地步
因為目前來看
股票市場根本就沒有
任何的避險情緒
可是長債實際利率不斷的升高
總有一天會回壓到股票市場
那美國股市是不是已經完全
消化完了本次的實際利率衝擊
我們細數一下到底目前市場上
針對債市拉警報的
根本原因有哪一些
目前彭博主要整理出了大概10個角度
10個利空
第一個就全球經濟真的很強
所以經濟強其實對於
債券反而是利空
債券通常在經濟衰退的時間最受歡迎
那現在美國的經濟表現還是非常強勁
最新所公佈的製造業
景氣也是維持在相對高點
經濟越強
資金當然是留在股票
或者相對的風險資產當中
那另外一方面也代表著
需求不容易快速的降溫
央行肯定沒有太多降息空間嘛
所以這第一個角度
就經濟太強
第二個呢
當然就是全球能源通膨的問題
由於原油價格已經外溢到食品價格
所以汽油柴油價格的上升以及
這一段時間
我們知道歐洲
全球各地受到熱浪的影響
食品價格的走高
通膨越高
未來收到固定利息和本金
實值購買力就越低
那投資人當然就會要求
更高的殖利率作為補償
再來呢是全球央行的確已經
慢慢進入到緊縮循環
從聯準會的升息
到日本央行韓國央行歐洲央行
全世界除了臺灣央行沒有升息以外
基本上能升的都已經升了
所以讓市場上有意識到
全球央行進入到新一輪的緊縮循環
這第三個原因
第四個原因就是來自於本輪的爆發點
AI的軍備競賽導致大量
投資等級債的發行
科技投資
者發行的總體債券呢
光是過去一整年就超過了4,000億美元
很大一部分集中在美國
所以搶奪了美國政府大量發債的買盤
最後呢使得國債殖利率必須要
付出更高的風險貼水
那第五個就是美國的
財政赤字的確很大
OECD國家今年需要融資18兆美元
美國政府債務已經超過了40兆
其實就是供需問題
政府發行的債券越來越多
而且都是短天期
即將要陸續到期了
買家的資金沒有同步增加
債券價格就會因此而下跌
此利率就會上升
再來有其他幾個原因
像是全球的軍費爆升
我們知道現在北約中東
亞洲都開始重新武裝
我們講的不是美伊戰爭哦
講的就是各國為了要
打造自己的國防供應鏈
必須要取更多的債
那再來呢
是日本從全球的資金
提供者變成了賣家
日本過去是長期維持超低利率
是全球相對最便宜的資金來源
結果現在日本升息了
日本去日本借日元
他是要錢的
以前是不用付利息的現在
過去我們講說借便宜日元來
買海外高收益資產的套利
交易已經開始正式逆轉了
所以日本現在不再是
一個免費的資金提供者了
那第八點是貿易戰讓全球
重新面對結構性的通膨
關稅戰其實還在持續
全球生產效率的下滑
成本提高
大家會要求債券更高的報酬
再來呢就是聯準會
和外國央行一樣哎的確
它也不再開始大量的持續買美債了
以前美債有兩群非常重要的買家
一個是聯準會
一個就是外國央行
這些機構在持有美債的情況底下
往往都不是為了追求報酬
都是因為貨幣政策
或者外匯存底的需求
像臺灣央行
你說美債賠不賠錢
它根本不管嘛
重點是台幣要值錢
就要買足夠多的美債
結果呢
現在很多的私人資金
包括資產管理機構
避險資金
他們非常看重價格
如果呢殖利率不夠高
就選擇不買了
而現在他們是主要的承接者
最後就是全球的
錢太多時代已經慢慢消失了
以前08年以來
全球有大量的儲蓄
追求有限的投資機會
現在卻完全相反
政府要錢AI要錢
能源轉型要錢
軍事擴張要錢
人口老化
退休金都要錢
全世界需要錢的地方越來越多
但是儲蓄沒有像以前這麼充沛
最後資金本身就變得昂貴
資金變昂貴的代價是什麼
就是利率提高嘛
好所以我們隨便一講
就講了10個理由
包括經濟太強
食品價格的上漲
全球央行緊縮循環
AI的軍備競賽
美國政府的斥資
全球軍費的暴增
日本央行正式從
資金提供者變成賣家
貿易戰的問題
還有外國承接者
全球錢太多的時代陸續消失其實
理由一堆了
其實我只是硬挑了10個
其實可以挑100個
跟那個沈玉琳講過的一樣
人家問他當小三有什麼好處
他說不用負責公婆嘛
不用當黃臉婆
每天只要開心相處就好了
那其實好處有30個
隨便講就3個
那現在美債殖利率到底上升
它的背後的根本原因有哪幾個
其實你可以找到100個
不過我們就挑10個重點來講
但是大概市場的敘事就在這
10個之間不斷的做移轉
與此同時
在短期內
市場上比較聚焦的壓力還是來自於
能夠觀察摸得到的新聞
因為剛才提到的那些角度
有很多根本就解決不了
你不要講說今年能不能解決
未來30年
美國政府財政赤字的問題能夠解決嗎
只要它還是世界第一強國
貿易逆差國本來就要繼續赤字嘛
所以在短期內
大家比較多做一些留意的是
美伊戰事的淡化以及通膨
在政策端能夠處理到什麼樣的位階
因為美國的能源庫存呢
最近又再度的拉響警報了
最新一周商業原油庫存增加了92.2萬桶
可是汽油庫存反而減少了168.4萬桶
哦所以從這樣的一個角度來做觀察
美國現在SPR戰略原油
儲備還在快速的下滑
尤其是中西部的汽油庫存
哦從數據來看
這應該是有記錄以來的最低
從來沒有美國庫存原油這麼低過
從這樣的一個角度來做思考
等同於
美國人口還在增長
照理來講
戰略原油儲備不能夠破敵的
可是市場上很明顯知道
川普其實能夠用的招已經用了
即便呢
有可能會損害到國防的利益
但是川普還是盡可能的把
戰略原油儲備盡可能的釋出
美國柴油現在每加侖
已經超過了6.5美元了
白宮最近已經開始
正在討論是否有必要開始
限制或者暫停柴油的出口
希望增加美國國內的供給
壓低價格
目前還沒有做出最後決定哦
不過如果為了期中選舉
我認為是有其必要的
要立即停止任何柴油的出口
來快速讓柴油價格能夠稍微適度下壓
那當然了
把自己的能源儲備做
適度的釋出是一個角度
可是剛才也看到SPR
其實位階已經很低了
再往下掉
美國國防供應鏈就會出事了
所以最好的方式是什麼呢
我們看白宮最近要求
歐洲盡可能去釋放柴油的戰略庫存
原因很簡單
就是因為美國現在
已經盡可能已經釋放了
可是你歐洲人呢
都還沒有做任何的柴油
戰略原油庫存的釋放
美國已經做了盡可能的事
來做緩和
那歐洲也要表達一些態度
那目前歐洲的能源專員已經
跟法國德國英國義大利還有
愛爾蘭官員來進行協商
美國是希望未來6個月內快速釋放
1.2億桶庫存
那能源業者估計
用這樣的一個效果能夠快速
的去壓低全球的柴油價格
不過看起來
歐洲內部也並不願意一次把
手上的安全庫存給大量用掉
現在很明顯是受到白宮的壓力
那白宮其實也有表達一定的態度了
他說我們也不是強迫你
我們也盡可能的把自己的
戰略原油儲備進行釋放了
但是你們總得表達出一些態度
幫助我們期中選舉好過關嘛
另外一方面
我們也清楚知道
其實歐洲帳面上1.95一桶
的柴油的戰略庫存呢
其實還算是偏高
相對於過去以往的水準呢
所以歐洲能不能
對本輪的能源局勢稍微產生緩和作用
這是值得觀察的重點的
現在美國的整體經濟
就處於一個非常有趣的位階
那就是美國現在經濟最大矛盾
就是利率其實對於股市是不太有利的
油價對於股市也是不太有利的
可是經濟和股市總是比
預期還要來得更為強勁
我們根據高盛的估算
美國在第三季的經濟年化
成長率大概可以來到3.4%
今年第四季相對於去年
第四季大概還會年成長2.2%
關鍵之一是什麼
利率明明在升高
可是我們都很清楚
知道整體金融環境呢
雖然略微收緊
可是它主要來自於內生經濟的爆發
錢變這麼貴
磁利率變這麼高
恰恰好就是內部的
經濟表現太好所導致的
就是因為人人都在搶錢
一個所有人都想要拿錢去做質押
去做進一步投資
那某種程度就是一個
經濟的增量的樂觀
社會那最後導致的結果就是
本來在樂觀的過程當中
錢就會越來越貴嘛
所以如果細節觀察
在過去八個季度
整體科技業的整體增幅大概
獲利成長
平均而言呢
在廢版大概是成長接近
有180%到280%左右
人工智慧相關的投資平均在
整體而言
光是投資就是年化成長26%
所以高油價到底有沒有去
侵蝕掉消費者的購買力
的確有
但是它不足以完全壓垮經濟
甚至光是在AI的投資
它就足以把整個經濟給往上帶
這就是真實跡象
從昨天公佈的9月份製造業PMI雖然呢
相對於初值略為下滑
可是還是創下了2022年5月
份以來的最高水準呢來到54.5
在ISMP製造業經理人採購指數的部分
這說明著新訂單仍然在快速的增加
尤其雖然我們知道有部分
民眾受到購買力的衝擊
可是初領申請失業救濟金呢
這還是只有19.7萬呢
就是你雖然現在過得很不好
可是也沒有到那種廣泛性失業
沒有工作可以做的地步
在這樣的一個效果底下
即便是續領失業救濟金人數
也創下了2023年3月份以來的最低哦
所以這就變成市場上最大矛盾
AI投資正在為製造業和
就業保持足夠的韌性
它也讓通膨更難以下滑
而且讓資金來得更為昂貴
所以這來講
資金昂貴會讓錢無法有效
產生在經濟的持續推升
可是它的內生經濟
正恰恰來自於
因為經濟太好
所以資金才會因此而昂貴
好這個有點因果的關係論
互相的維持
不過至少可以看到
我們很容易把過去活過的世界
就是誤以為原本的樣子
過去十幾年呢
我們迎來的時代是什麼
就全球化嘛
然後壓低生產成本
能源價格又很便宜
全球儲蓄很充沛
金融海嘯之後
全球央行基本上都維持相對低利率
所以企業已經習慣這種便宜錢
很長一段時間了
結果呢
發現利率現在要突然回到高位
大家覺得無法接受
利率這麼高一定會死人的
唉結果真實表現的跡像是什麼
就是大家開始習慣
一個新的高利率社會
因為經濟變好了
經濟變好
所以錢本身就要更值錢
錢的更值錢單位就是利率
這兩天我才去那個維也納
佛洛伊德的故居
去做一些這個
算是致敬
一走進去
其實有一件事情我特別驚訝
一直覺得很奇怪
因為佛洛德很有名嘛
當年他也在這裡生活
看診這麼多年了
我發現那個房子有點空
那我原本想說
我應該看到那個傢俱
尤其是那個病人不是在躺著
做那精神分析的沙發
都不在這裡
後來我才知道
這是佛洛德人生最後
一段最戲劇化的故事
就是1938年
納粹德國併吞奧地利
那佛洛德是猶太人
遭到迫害
82歲了他還要被迫離開已經
住了幾十年的維也納
流亡到倫敦
那他很多的傢俱
著名的那個
診療的沙發都帶去英國了
好這件事情對我最大衝擊是什麼
就是一個人呢
他花了幾十年建立自己的
事業理論名聲或者生活
晚年八十幾歲了
突然之間整個大改變
被迫離開以為自己會住一輩子的家
所以我覺得
我們對照今天的高利率時代
環境改變的速度
有時候遠遠比人類
想像的速度還要來得快
我們很容易用昨天的世界去預測明天
覺得08年以後
經濟差不多就這樣子
一輩子都不會好轉了
我們永遠都要處在寬鬆的社會
甚至負利率時代即將到來
想不到過了20年
高利率時代已經到來了
AI時代已經爆發了
那這個時候資金重新變成昂貴的時代
包括
政府的財政
企業的估值
房地產股票的本益比
過去我們習慣的資產配置的方式
也許都必須要重新的適應
這給投資朋友做一些思考了
其實我們還是可以觀察到
市場上還是有暴食的
對於AI比較戒慎恐懼的角度
這也是好事情
至少有一個提醒者嘛
你像最近大賣空的
嗯Michael Berry
最近又再度針對AI熱潮提出強烈警告
昨天他發文了
他說如果真的讓Openai跟
Anthropic如果能夠順利地上市
可能會從資本市場當中
吸收數兆美元的資金
那最後呢
我們應該為了
不希望股票市場出現足夠大的崩盤
我們應該阻止這兩家
公司推進首次的公開募股那當然
它的背後核心還是AI的龐大投資
能不能產生足夠的回報
如果大家真的把錢都投到這些
還沒有具體營收回饋的企業
那你只是把人類的金融
世界完全跟這兩家企業
掛上鉤那最後所造成的崩盤
全人類都會因此而受害
這也很有趣哦
Michael Berry
以前是資本支出太高
不切實際看空
後來是估值太高看空
第一體景氣
最後變成供給過剩看空
現在為了人類
你知道嗎
為了人類的福祉
他也看空
這高度越來越高
但是至少可以看得出來
市場上
在不同的認知當中
我們看Michael Berry
他就是依照的過去的庫存循環供給
過剩的角度來做思考
根據過去的資本支出的循環
根據過往的估值來做一個判斷
那會不會AI時代
我們必須用不同的標準來判斷呢
有時候看
瞭解說
這個時代
也許慢慢改變
以前我們跟大家分享過嘛
以前港片不是有一部叫
中國最後一個太監嘛
那裡面那個主角就叫來喜嘛
這清朝已經搖搖欲墜
革命黨四起
眼看就要翻頁了
那你知道窮苦人家最大的問題是什麼
就是他不知道時代變了這
到處都革命黨了
你還到進宮
然後去切掉小雞雞
所以最後
我們看到
因為他是最後是服侍溥儀皇室嘛
有時候小時候看到這段電影都很難過
怎麼會這樣呢
都已經知道世界要改變了
你還把自己命根子送出去
但有時候我們講說
很多時候大家不知道時代變了
但是從很多的數據看得出來
時代已經慢慢改變了
這是我們要予以警惕的
好那回過頭來說現在
其實從經濟數據來看
美國經濟最有趣的地方
就是高利率維持了這麼久
經濟沒有如市場原先
擔心的那樣快速的衰退
企業投資和就業還是有韌性
我們看美股股市在昨天
仍然保持在高位震盪
AI資本支出繼續支撐住
目前的製造和整體消費
對一般而言
高利率和高物價帶來
的壓力沒有消失哦
可是最後反映的效果是什麼
就是其實總體數據表現的並不差
真正的代價是政治上的
我們看到最新川普民調顯示
川普的淨支持度已經
來到-22.7個百分點
創下本屆任期以來的新低了在本周
好所以這就是一個很有意思的反差
高利率到底有沒有把美國經濟給打垮
我的看法是沒有
但是它透過房貸透過
車貸透過信用卡的利率
還有生活成本的壓力
它先把川普民調給擠垮了
好這是最終結論了
所以高利率到底對於
經濟有沒有衝擊
有但是沒有想像中來的大
恰恰相反
正由於經濟夠強
才會有如此高的利率
而唯一受害的很明顯
是執政黨
是川普目前的民調壓力
那當然回過頭看臺股
台股這一鋪
到底有沒有因此受賄和受害的地方呢
台股第一個交易日在10月份呢
震盪走高
其實還是創下了收盤新高
來在48,353點
成交金額來到8,374億
從這樣的一個角度來做思考
台股其實相對於美國
股市強勁的非常多
原因就來自於我們在AI
循環站穩了重要的位階
針對國發會所公佈的
8月景氣對策信號燈
又來到41分
連續三個月持平
呈現高度的擴張格局
如果我們細看分項
除了M1B還在綠燈
那是貨幣的問題
我們看到其他像是
工業服務的加班工時
製造業營業氣候測驗點呢
通常以往因為傳產壓力很大嘛
所以通常指標表現並不好
現在要麼就是紅燈
要麼就是黃紅燈
結果呢
我們從今年1月份以來
應該從去年12月份開始
就已經連續9個月都
保持高強度的紅燈
跟著我一起闖紅燈吧
我們看得很清楚
其實可以發現臺灣的景氣概況
前所未有的大好
從三大科學園區半年的營收來做思考
臺灣三大科學園區在26年上半年
的營收合計是增長了3.54兆元
這也是歷史同期的新高
南科的部分是一兆7,739億
年增幅28%
竹科的部分是一兆1,195億
年增幅36%
其實南科在三年前就
已經超越竹科的營收了
從整個AI伺服器和算力建設
從整體需求來看
你可以看得出來
中科也不錯
中科上半年營收是6,436億
成長幅度大概也有20.63%哦
好這都反映出整個AI熱潮
它不是單純反映在營收
它已經轉化成新一輪投資和就業
三大園區就業人數是34萬人
竹科有18萬人
南科10萬人
中科6萬人
而且你要知道哦
南科現在的營收比足科高
可是南科的人數只有10萬人
足科有18萬人哦
好所以其實中南部地區目前的AI
投資紅利上升幅度也非常快
好這麼高強度的一個營收發展
對於工程師的業績
足以貢獻
我們看最新在昨天
2026年安聯所公佈的全球財富報告
臺灣在去年年底的人均金融資產淨值
居然已經高達16.4萬歐元
新臺幣折合594萬元
已經晉升到全球第五名了
僅次於美國的296,000元
瑞士的27萬
丹麥19萬
新加坡的19萬
也比日本的8.9萬高非常多
大概是日本的接近兩倍左右
臺灣家庭的總金融
資產也成長8.7%
來到4.5兆歐元呢
扣掉7,142億的歐元負債以後
淨金融資產來到3.8兆歐元
年增幅是9.1%
這個也跑贏了通膨
其實如果細節觀察了
我們大概分成兩種指標來做思考
一個是人均
淨金融資產
這是左邊
就是我們把現金把
存款把股票基金保險
全部加起來
然後扣除掉你的房貸
扣除掉你的信貸
你的質押
除以人口
這個比較偏向家庭
真正擁有的金融資產
現在是排行全球第五名
那排行第六名的是人均金融總資產
就是我不看負債了
那數字一定比較高嘛
那整體而言呢
大概是排第六
不管怎麼看哦臺灣
我們當然知道
因為我跟郭董
平均身價也是數百億起跳
我要講的概念是哦
你的老闆很明顯比其他
國家的老闆有錢非常多
這是跟不是跟台日韓來做對比哦
這個日本韓國已經
遠遠被臺灣拋在後面了
我們講的是其他先進國家
基本上不管是加拿大
澳洲荷蘭紐西蘭
臺灣的金融總資產都比這些
國家的金融總資產還要來得高
這是扣除掉負債的情況底下
當然了
有一部分可能是我們知道
臺灣這幾年估值快速的提升
這是去年數據哦
去年台股也才
年底也才3萬點以下嘛
現在4萬8哦
所以你說2026年這個
排名會不會再往前呢
臺北股市有沒有跑贏新加坡股市
有有沒有跑贏跑贏丹麥股市
跑贏瑞士股市
照這個速度
過幾年你要說超越
新加坡也不是太難的事情了
超越丹麥也不是太難了
基本上準備就是挑戰瑞士美國了
按照這個速度
所以我們當然並不是
說平均每個人594萬
每個人就有594萬但是
就算用財富集中k型
分化的角度而言
臺灣的大股東
臺灣的老闆
都已經比全世界其他的大
股東和老闆相對來的有錢了
這個就是我們講的游資
要區分成兩種一個是
財富分配的問題
另外一個是你的老闆
有沒有比其他國家的老闆有錢
那這樣才有加薪理由嘛OK
這給投資票做些思考了
當然呢最大的問題來自於哪裡
最大的問題當然就來自於臺灣呢
很有趣的一個跡象就是
明明人均淨資產正在快速提升
可是我們卻觀察到
在最近銀行業卻出現了錢荒
哎這什麼事情呢
就臺灣銀行業
這幾個月大家也感受到了
雖然是沒有升息了
可是你已經感覺到銀行自己已經先
自主升息了
央行是沒有升息
可是錢越來越不好貸了
最明顯的數字就是
銀行的流動覆蓋率
就是衡量銀行能不能靠手上的現金
公債央行的存單這些高流動性的資產
來撐過未來30天的資金大量流出的
指標法定最低標準是100%了
現在大概在115左右
唉前陣子
今年年初是130哦
等於是半年就少掉了15個百分點
甚至傳出銀行有在本月月中
一度跌破100%的法定的底線
他最後是靠調度資金才重新
在月底重新拉回標準之上
那這些事情就意味著銀行
現在的確缺錢的壓力已經
反映到企業和民眾的借貸成本了
那很多銀行為了要守住流動性呢
還拜託一些大額的存款
客戶不要把錢領走
還要控制放款和撥款的速度
那怎麼會發生這樣的一個跡象呢
明明錢進來的速度這麼快其實
主要的原因有兩個
第一個是
市場資金移轉更快了
錢一進來馬上就進股市
所以反而能夠放款的錢不多
能買股票的錢很多了
但是要去借錢的
沒有人願意
就沒有人想要把錢停留在銀行
讓銀行去放款
因為你只能領活期或者定存的錢嘛
那我寧願買股票
所以銀行就沒錢了
那第二種角度是來自於臺灣
企業赴美投資的規模非常龐大
所以有很多錢
我們認列財報是很龐大
可是錢沒回來
就直接落地在亞利桑那
在日本的熊本就直接設廠
繼續擴廠了
好所以這是產生的雙重效果
但它根本背後的一個角度
其實就來自於目前整體遊資的
概況和體感溫度的一個區別
當然最後
市場上最為關注的還是
那你剛才說到瑞銀所公佈的
應該講不應該不是講瑞銀
安聯所公佈的總體
財富的淨資產持續創高
到底薪資角度為何呢
其實如果是從去年年底來看
全體臺灣的平均勞動報酬是88.3萬元
比前一年增加了3萬左右
不過呢如果細節觀察一個變數
就是固定每個月可以
預期拿到的經常性的薪資
占整體勞動報酬比重
已經降到65%
比10年前還少了3個百分點反而是
薪資獎金分紅加班費
上升到21個百分點
比10年前增加了3個百分點
什麼意思
就現在企業
更喜歡發獎金呢
不願意直接加底薪呢好
那你大概理解老闆為什麼會這樣幹呢
就是很多企業無法
確認AI繁榮會維持多久
所以更傾向用一次性的獎金留才
而並不是提高你的固定薪資
那其實就意味著
接下來即便AI持續繁榮
它在用這樣的一個方式
你就可能稍微能夠按耐住你哦
可是只要AI當年度
財報沒有表現特別好
它就不給你發獎金了
所以整體而言
市場未來的薪資波動
幅度可能會持續的加大
這也是我們看到帳面上
現在有可能最便宜最划算的選擇
不一定是真正成本最低的選擇
因為每個人害怕的風險不同嘛
經濟學上很多決策都不是
用眼前的價格來做計算
而是把未來可能發生
的一件事情算進去
你要硬要這樣講
好像老闆也是有道理的
當一個決定很容易做
但是卻很難反悔的時候
現在很多企業就寧願多付一點成本
換取未來的彈性
好對於企業來講
景氣好的時候直接加薪了
看起來每個月好像只多付一點錢了
可是未來底薪一旦提高
就變成長期的固定成本了
我們並不是講說財富分配的角度
我們講說從老闆的利益來看呢
他就會這樣幹好
所以我們才會導致財富暴增速度加快
但是底
心卻遠遠跟不上的一個感覺
如果未來景氣反轉
獲利下滑
他可能就覺得
那我收不回來了
那我乾脆不要去建立
一個未來很難收回的承諾
哎這就是目前觀察到的事實方向
就很多時候我們人
願意付出的額外成本
其實是在替自己買一個未來的確定性
這個是目前臺灣的
老闆大概心裡的想法
之前講一個故事嘛
講一對老夫妻
去以色列旅行
突然太太心臟病發過世
當地葬儀社就告訴丈夫
埋在這裡只要100美金
但如果要把她運回國安葬的話
要1萬美元
那丈夫想了想
嗯還是幫我運回去好了
那葬儀社的人很驚訝
這裡可是聖地
而且便宜這麼多
那丈夫搖搖頭嘛
我聽說以前有一個男的埋在這裡
三天之後又復活了
我不想冒這個風險了
所以現在
不管是企業對於AI紅利的態度
你看AI帶動臺灣的科技業成長
很多企業現在就是需要一個是什麼
需要一個
未來一個確定性
人願意付出的額外成本
其實就是在替自己買
一個未來的確定性
他寧願給你多一點獎金
給你極度亮麗
在當年的額外的紅利回饋
他也不願意調高
一點點你的固定薪資
好這個就是市場上
不想冒這樣的一個風險呢
當然不代表說企業不相信AI
他相信現在很好
但他還沒法確信以後
每一年都會這麼好
這就是我們觀察到的實質跡象了
當然呢
這就是雙方需要進行
勞資協調的部分
所以才去
需要在趁現在缺工的情況底下
繼續的做協商嘛
這個才是勞團目前應該做的事情
我們看到跟資方的一個糾結
有必要繼續持續
畢竟現在有利的是勞方
市場大缺工嘛
AI紅利大好
當然應該要順勢的調
高自己的固定薪資
回過頭說
對於政府而言呢
那就是財富分配嘛
我們看到立院最新會期開議之後
普發現金再度成為了朝野的攻防焦點
目前行政院是規劃27年每人普發1萬塊
總額是2,357億
希望在農曆年前後會發放
那國民黨團
是主張加碼每人2萬元
並且嚴擬透過特別條例來推動
並且提出修改預演算法的構想
未來稅收只要超過預算一定規模
就直接進行固定分配
按還稅於民
當然呢我們先不去講說程式的問題
立院照理來講沒辦法做直接性的規劃
然後來進行發放
不過回過頭說
那至少兩黨都想要發嘛
一個發多一個發少嘛那
還稅於民呢
某種政策而言呢
你都發現了
沒有人考慮退稅
沒有沒有一個黨團考慮退稅
目的什麼
好因為這是一個
財富再分配的過程
大家都已經認可了
並不是你多繳一點稅
你就多退一點了
基本上就是只要超征
永遠都是進行普發來回饋民眾
那某種程度它就是一種
財富分配的一個角度
來緩解我們在k型分化
當中所遇到的一個問題
好這個就是行政院
和立法院
或者我們講說不同黨團
目前所給予的態度
當然呢你說那錢是不是應該撥到
其他地方更有道理的呢
比如說現在勞保的收支已經連續11年
進入到短處
勞保的財務壓力越來越大
再來看我們這也知道
在軍公教的部分呢
在最近
教師節才剛過嘛
我們看臺灣教育產業工會
好最近公佈了教育施政滿意度調查
好基層對於中央政府教育的評分呢
10分滿分只有2.37分呢
很多人認為
那是不是在教師層面呢
應該要做進一步的加薪之前是
在國防部有適度做調薪嘛
那有沒有可能在各大領域
公家部門
進行全面性的調升
大家都在做做觀察
某種程度而言呢
其實我們講的事情是
不管是對於美國
我們今天的主軸
對於經濟持續保持在成長的過程當中
但是川普的民調卻創下了
算是本屆以來的新低
臺灣市場也是如此
我們的人均淨資產金融
淨資產全部都在創高
可是民眾的生活感受是否有變好
它在變成兩件事情了
美國經濟是很強了
那民調很明顯他就不看好嘛
臺灣的AI出口股市其實不斷地創高
但我們明顯感受到
財富和薪資的紅利
它並不是一個平均的分配
所以從這樣的一個角度來說
一個國家最困難的
現在看起來也不是AI成長的問題
是如何讓這一波成長
讓大多數人能夠感受得到
不過至少可以確認的事情是
你感不感受得到
跟它是否會創高
它是完全兩個不同的問題
給投資朋友做些思考了
今天主要跟投資朋友稍微梳理一下
美國經濟和臺灣經濟的概況以及
背後政府所面臨的挑戰為何
給投資朋友做些思考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱按讚加分享
台股小跌21點
收在48,332點
創新高休息一下
好那我們後續再來跟投資朋友
追蹤全球這種AI時代的浪潮
那是不是代表著淨資產的提高
財富效應可以推動
全球經濟好一陣子呢
給投資朋友做些思考
如果喜歡我們節目
記得幫我們訂閱
按讚加分享
我們就禮拜一早上8點半
早晨財經速解讀再相見